we've literally spent a year basically
doing therapy kind of working through
some things and and figuring out what
this next chapter would look like
that's Nick Jonas with his brothers
Kevin and Joe opening up about what it
took to get the band back together after
six years apart on The Late Late Show
Monday night we've had to be really open
and honest and you know there are things
in the past I think bothered us from
time to time even in our performances
that we would do make admits it all came
flashing back to him when the guys
recently performed their first show
together I was so paranoid for the first
two or three songs that they're gonna be
mad at me after this that I was like not
able to enjoy it then it's a certain
points look that was like this is
amazing I'm gonna have the best time
ever when we did it was a great show the
Jonas Brothers weren't originally set on
reuniting in fact the trio was filming
an upcoming Amazon Studios documentary
at the time which was supposed to be
about their childhood their time in the
band and their present-day lives
separate lives doing separate things Joe
with dnce me and me with my solo stuff
and during that time you know we started
to realize there was a magic that we
felt like we were missing and you know
so the process was basically just why
don't we give us a shot nick says all
the pieces just sort of fell into place
we start to play a little music together
and realize right away this is where
we're meant to be in our lives at this
moment the Jonas Brothers released their
first new song in nearly six years last
week a catchy hit called sucker about
being head over heels in relationships
[Music]
of course all three of the brothers are
in relationships Joe is engaged to
sophie turner kevin is married with two
daughters - danielle jonas and nick is
married to priyanka chopra it's so
amazing to have someone out there
rooting for you and you know that that's
your partner and they're always on your
team and whatever happens that's your
person and there's such an amazing
security in that I loved it Priyanka
Sophie and Danielle were all on hand to
root for their men on the set of sucker
in fact they stole the show with their
epic cameos et recently caught up with
Anthony Mandler the director of the
sucker music video and he revealed all
the juicy behind-the-scenes details
including how they kept it off the
public's radar the only way we kept his
secrets that we did it very quickly I
think we shot two weeks ago and and I'm
they contacted me a week earlier so the
whole thing it was shot at a place
called Hatfield house which is about 45
minutes out of central London but it's
it's one of the largest private
residences in England so we're behind
walls and a lot of sort of like barriers
so we were able to do what we were able
to do but you know I've seen I've seen
in my career seen drones and helicopters
and tall ladders so I was expecting
actually
[Music]